hello we are so honored to be here
tonight as actors because we realize
that thousands of people are involved
behind the scenes making these projects
what they are and truthfully we are
honored tonight to be giving you guys
the recognition that you all deserve as
you saw in the opening of our film we
have a teen awards plus a medal of
commendation and two Oscars to head out
tonight so we're going to keep things
moving along what oh we're gonna try
what these awards really represents is
some of the most amazing movies the
effects and the work all build on each
other from Close Encounters to avatar
2001 to star wars Iron Man Superman the
Avengers it's pretty cool to be in a
room full of people who create
superheroes you know I think you're the
only one in the room with real
superpowers Kristen you know Veronica
Mars kicked ass with that Kickstarter it
certainly did I am grateful and
technology is wonderful serious let's
get out some awards it used to be that
flipping cars the old-school way use
hidden ramps sometimes even cannons were
fired underneath them send them flying
these days the pneumatic car flipper can
safely flip cars or trucks in any
direction it can launch you can launch
with angle precision to a designated
landing area first developed on the set
of Armageddon this groundbreaking piece
of equipment is easy to set up and
strike and it's a lot less disruptive
than explosives especially if you're
driving for the design and development
of the pneumatic car flipper the Academy
presents a technical achievement award
to John Frazier Chuck Gasper and clay
penny gentlemen
laughs all right Zach I just like to
take a moment to thank all of the people
that were very patient with me when I
first started out Glenn Robinson johnny
burke guys when i was in my late 20s
early 30s I certainly knew more than
they did or so I believed anyway this
was developed Chuck started developing
it we refined it specifically for
independence day John has since made
more refinements that shot was from
total recall using one of John's new and
improved ones so it's just safety
reliability putting stunt men close to
them and having a shot that we know what
it's going to work Thank You Johnny got
some time what you do so what you're
looking at is a couple of old guys after
they just have a lot of fun making
movies but we are between the two of us
is 100 years of special-effects
technology her so we developed this car
flipper and what it came about because
it was the for the safety of everybody
we were shooting downtown a lot and it's
a lot of requirements was no noise and
we had to know exactly where the cars
were good on land when we lost him so we
came up with that that idea and it's
actually been the standard of the
industry for probably the last 30 years
maybe uncle Amos is night yeah used
around the world it's the safest way to
launch a static car or other things to
Armageddon we launched parts of
asteroids so it's um it's a pretty
versatile tool it it's quick to set up
and quick the strike so that's why we
get along with Michael Bay so well so
don't want to take any of his freshest
I'm and thank the rest of you for
helping us cover up our wires and the
other things that we can't keep out